[Music]
thank you for joining spectator TV
Debbie this week you write about the
Scottish government's planned ban on
conversion therapy and how it is perhaps
more Sinister than it first seems on
paper can you tell us more well you've
got to ask why the Scottish government
is so keen on pushing this legislation
and pushing it now if you read through
the consultation it their own
consultation it's clear that uh there is
little need for any new laws uh coercive
and abusive practices are already
illegal and they struggle to actually
find any examples of where this law will
actually catch things that that the
other law wouldn't so you got ask why
they're doing it and the uh the concern
the whole time is that it will
criminalize normal exploratory therapy
so that uh so that therapists cannot
challenge patients on what they they say
about themselves and most worryingly of
all in my view when children are
involved uh therapists may be in a
position where they're unable to do
anything apart from blindly affirm what
the child tells them yes and Debbie in
your article you give an example of
potentially someone going around to
speak to a friend who's who's thinking
about uh transitioning and how they
could fall fou of this can can you talk
us through the example you
offer well it's just not clear what he's
going to what he's going to be
criminalized and what is's not what is
not uh the consultation talks about
safeguards but uh we're talking about uh
pushing the uh criminality further than
what it is at the moment so at the
moment it's a criminal offense to try to
uh con change somebody's sexual
orientation uh if you mean them harm and
that should surely be enough so to push
that further suggests to me that the the
the Scottish government is looking at uh
is looking at those normal conversations
where people don't mean anybody any harm
they just want to try and help Michael
can you talk us through the Practical
implications of what's being proposed so
the The Proposal that they have here is
um is quite extensive there's a lot that
they're that they're trying to do and
simultaneously there's a lot that
they're expressly saying that they're
not trying to do um so Debbie has
mentioned that the um there's a lot of
this that's already covered by um
existing criminal laws there a lot of
things that we would ordinarily
understand when we think of the phrase
kind of conversion therapy that would
just be already covered under the law
relating to assault or um kind of
anything that relates to kind of a
physical um attack on on an individual
so what they're trying to capture here
is thought talking to people um and
trying to convince people in the process
of talking with them uh to change or to
suppress their sexual orientation or
their gender identity or their own
perception of their sexual orientation
or their um gender identity but there's
a car out in the propos proposal to um
ensure that if you're engaging this from
the perspective of a healthcare provider
um that's not going to be um captured by
the proposal so it seems like the only
people who are actually going to be
captured by this proposal um the most
likely people are going to be people
like family members or friends of
individuals who are talking to them and
are going beyond what you would
ordinarily kind of describe as just kind
of exploring someone's identity but for
example let's say you have a a mother of
a of a teenager and the um the teenager
is a biological female um who has in the
past expressed um same-sex attraction
and is now identifying as a boy now if
the parent had responded to that child
and said no you look you're not you're
not a a heterosexual boy you're probably
dealing with some kind of internalized
homophobia you likely are just a lesbian
and we love you and we um are happy to
um affirm that well that could become a
criminal offense now uh because what's
happening there is that the the parent
is um is purposely trying to um engage
in a conversation that is challenging
the individual self assessment of their
own identity that's the most likely
thing to be practically captured by this
now realistically it's it's unclear um
whether or not these are the kind of
things that are going to um result in uh
the police getting involved necessarily
but the bill also includes uh provision
for protective orders that would allow
third parties um potentially even
campaigning organizations so long as
they can demonstrate uh connection to
the to the family to be able to seek a
court order to um interfere in the
relationship between the parent and
child in that context so practically
speaking what we more likely to see here
is something that we've seen in other
areas of law around this um area which
is that the legislation is relatively
tightly drafted and is intended to
capture a very small sliver of uh
protectional forms of conduct and then
um it's then represented outside of the
legislative legal framework in kind of
society and in um advocacy organizations
as something much more broadly
encompassing than it actually is will
then which will then create a chilling
effect or will will create this kind of
practical problem that causes um people
to modify their behavior even if what
they would have been doing in the past
is not this new criminal offense so
there's a real danger that people um
talking to their family members or their
friends and expressing views like I
don't think it's possible to change
biological sex people might think that
that's being captured by this bill when
in fact it's not the bill specifically
has a carot for that as well so there's
a lot of car votes in this bill um or
this proposal um that will you know it
shows that the Scottish government has
been thinking about the the implications
of this for um potential legal
challenges that they might be facing and
so the actual thing that as Debbie says
that the the bill is trying to do is
extremely narrow um but the the rhetoric
around it and the discussion around it
might make it seem to be much more
broader than it actually is and the
narrow thing that it's doing um is
itself open to Challenge from people who
are of the Viewpoint that you shouldn't
be criminalizing those kinds of
discussions between friends and family
members for example yes Debbie in
Westminster there's been talk in the
past about these conversion therapy
bands but often it's just being seen as
too complicated in terms of legislation
in terms of unintended consequences is
um enacting it do you do you think the
S&P government uh thinks it's found a
perfect solution or do you think
something else is driving it in terms of
why they're so focused on this
particularly after the gender
recognition act well you'd think after
they uh got into so much hot water over
the gender recognition Reform Bill that
they would leave this well alone but uh
once again it seems to the SNP
government trying to uh trying trying to
work I would say outside their remit
even in the in these proposals it talk
talks about Provisions made for somebody
who is removed from Scotland uh so you
can have a situation where a
conversation is perfectly legal in
England but because somebody is
habitually resident in Scotland and
they're taken to England for that
conversation it can then be illegal in
Scotland that that that will that could
become a criminal offense uh under these
proposals and it just seems to me once
again it's the S&P government is trying
to legislate outside what uh what is
their remit of a default of devolved uh
Authority yeah Michael how do you think
that will work because obviously we've
previously seen uh the S&P government
fail and it came to their um as de's
mentioning their last uh big gender
recognition policy and it was challenged
by the UK government successfully is
this going to create any issues like
that in the sense of uh how it works
across uh you know over to England and
Scotland I think there there's less of a
of a risk of that with with this bill
partially because um the Scotland act
actually has a number of instances where
we've seen legislation that is um that
looks like it might have a crossb
implication but um but actually doesn't
so the a classic example of this might
be um taxing people on property that
they own in Scotland or taxing people
who are resident on property that they
own outside of Scotland that's been um
that would be kind of understood pretty
clearly as being within the competency
of the Scottish Parliament to be able to
legislate on the issue here um is is
kind of twofold and it's more related to
things like um human rights so um things
like the freedom of expression freedom
of religion freedom of belief and
there's an assessment in this proposal
that says that they've considered the
impact that this um proposed legislation
would have on the ability of um people
to express their religious beliefs or to
engage in religious practices or
philosophical beliefs we know that
gender critical feminism is a is a
protected philosophical belief as well
and the Scottish government has said
that they don't think there's going to
be a significant impact um on the
enjoyment of the rights that people
have and if you look specifically or
strictly at the the bill itself those um
or the proposals that they have um they
have narrowly tailored this to ensure
that it's only going to be affecting a
small sliver of conduct but there could
still potentially be human rights
challenges that um occur here and those
challenges that they got Parliament is
not empowered to breach international
human rights obligations under the
European Convention of uh of Human
Rights and so um you you could
potentially see challenges here um as
well and you could also see challenges
in terms of how the proposals are
implemented so it's one thing if on the
books it says that they're not going to
be using this to um criminalize people
expressing their uh their lawfully held
views or they're not going to use it to
criminalize um therapists engaging in
explo latory therapy with um patients
but if in practice that's what the
police end up doing if in practice you
end up getting a call uh from a police
officer that says look you've not
actually breached the law but you're in
real danger of doing so and I want to
warn you and I'm going to record this as
a hate incident and we've seen this kind
of examples happening in the past um
Scotland is is is in a different
situation to and the United Kingdom as a
whole because Scotland's constitutional
framework places very Express
on um the legislative capacity of
Scotland I don't think that this bill
would be out with the capacity of the
Scottish Parliament but its
implementation might run into human
rights challenges and Debbie uh just
finally what do you think you know is
there a chance this doesn't become law
we've seen in the past uh when it comes
to the S&P ranks Kate Forbes Ash Reagan
have been questioning of him Yousef and
the green party in some of the direction
here could we see a bit of push back
potentially well politically it's very
interesting and it's the basis of the
government in Scotland how much this has
been driven by the greens by the
Scottish greens and how much by the S&P
itself is not certain and as the uh NE
as the general election approach is uh
the S&P must be looking at their uh
knocking on doors and thinking about
their voters and realizing that this
this sort of legislation is not what the
voters are looking for you know there's
far more pressing concerns of the the
people of Scotland have got far more
pressing concerns than what Michael has
described as very very narrow
legislation that uh will pick up very
little thank you Debbie thank you
[Music]
Michael